This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一档 I-Heart 播客节目。内容绝对真人。欢迎收听《回首当年》（Look Back at it）播客。从 1979 年开始，这对我和我都是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我来说意义重大。我是 Sam J.。我是 Alex English。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代。84 年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首当年》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欢迎收听《艰难之路》（Learn the Hardway），我是你最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不够安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须要这么做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难之路》。2023 年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，这份特定的检测报告是你篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改了一次检测报告。这需要一大批网络侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋，迈克尔·兰吉尼（Michael Ranjini）。我的天哪，我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立恢复力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
也就是 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 上的 TWA percent，或者在任何你获取播客的地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然都是同一个多产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜》（the girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes. and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. You guys might not want me to say this, but like it or not, we are coming closer to the end of the year and also the whole. holidays, Thanksgiving, Christmas, Hanukkah, New Year. And famously, there is a huge emphasis on reflecting on the year and showing gratitude for our lives. So I thought, what better time than now
大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变革与过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析二十岁的心理。你们可能不想让我这么说，但不管你愿不愿意，我们都在接近年末，同时还有整个假期，感恩节、圣诞节、光明节、新年。而且众所周知，人们非常强调反思过去的一年以及对生活心怀感激。所以我想，还有什么比现在更好的时机呢？
to do an episode on gratitude, which for some reason I have never done before. I don't know exactly how I've missed it, but today is the day. Also, before we get into it, I want to let you know this episode is actually also a video episode on YouTube. So if you prefer watching episodes with video and getting to like see, I don't know, see me speaking to you through a screen, go and check that out. I'll leave a link in the description. But let's get into it. Gratitude journals, gratitude challenges, daily affirmations. You know, I even have a daily affirmations, well, weekly affirmations podcast. It's everywhere. If you've ever opened Instagram, which I'm assuming you have, you have probably seen a post at some time at some point about manifesting abundance.
做一期关于感恩的节目，出于某种原因，我以前从未做过。我不知道自己究竟是怎么漏掉它的，但今天就是这一天。另外，在深入探讨之前，我想告诉大家，这期节目其实也是 YouTube 上的视频节目。所以如果你更喜欢观看带视频的节目，并且能够看到，我不知道，看到我通过屏幕和你说话，那就去看看吧。我会在简介里留一个链接。但我们还是进入正题吧。感恩日记、感恩挑战、每日肯定。你知道，我甚至还有一个每日肯定，嗯，每周肯定的播客。它无处不在。如果你打开过 Instagram，我假设你打开过，你大概在某个时候看到过关于吸引力法则（manifesting abundance）的帖子。
If you've ever been to therapy, chances are you have encountered a therapist that has encouraged gratitude. I know I shall have. It is presented to us as this almost like magical cure all. Be grateful and you will be happy. People talk about gratitude like it is this like magic pill, this magic way to be a more happy, well-rounded person. In some ways, it is. But that claim can feel a little bit too neat, a little bit too like one-dimensional. Can it really fix everything? Probably not.
如果你去看过心理医生，你很有可能会遇到一个鼓励你心怀感恩的治疗师。我知道我有过。它呈现在我们面前，几乎就像是一种神奇的万灵药。心怀感恩，你就会快乐。人们谈论感恩时，把它说得像一颗神奇的丸子，是成为一个更快乐、更全面的人的神奇方法。在某些方面，确实如此。但这种说法会让人觉得有点过于完美，有点过于一维。它真的能解决所有问题吗？可能不行。
Is it always that easy to tap into? Definitely not. But today, we're going to talk about it. And we're going to ask that big question. Does gratitude actually make us happier? And what forms or ways of expressing? gratitude are the most effective. We're going to look at, of course, the psychology. Do I even need to say that? Probably not. The neuroscience. And also, importantly, the limits of gratitude. Because yes,
它总是那么容易做到吗？绝对不是。但今天，我们要来聊聊这个话题。我们要问那个宏大的问题：感恩真的能让我们更快乐吗？以及表达感恩的形式或方式有哪些是最有效的？当然，我们要探讨心理学。我甚至还需要说这个吗？可能不需要。神经科学。还有，同样重要的是，感恩的局限性。因为是的，
it is amazing. Yes, it does fundamentally change your brain. There's also a more nuanced side to it. Toxic gratitude can elicit a lot of guilt and a pressure to be thankful and it can actually stop or halt emotional processing, that needs to be part of the conversation. So I am excited to dive deeper into this topic. It has been a long time coming without further ado. Let's get into the psychology of gratitude. First things first, definition of gratitude. We need to kind of get that ironed out.
它太棒了。是的，它确实从根本上改变了你的大脑。但它也有更微妙的一面。有毒的感恩会引发很多内疚感和保持感激的压力，它实际上会阻止或中断情绪处理，这需要成为对话的一部分。所以我很高兴能深入探讨这个话题。这已经酝酿很久了。废话不多说。让我们进入感恩心理学。首先第一件事，感恩的定义。我们需要把这个理清楚。
This is actually, ironically, kind of a hard concept to get a clear definition on. One of the best ways it's described in that I found it described was actually in a 2010 paper written by researchers in Ohio who actually talked about how gratitude is both a trait. So for example, some people just naturally feel more grateful. And it's also an attitude or an emotion. It's also something that we can elicit for ourselves and kind of force into occurring. there are even more definitions about this. Is gratitude also just like a coping response? Is it a coping mechanism? Is gratitude like a spiritual experience? Is it just something that like we have to trip into to find? Is it just something that comes up spontaneously? A lot of people actually have
这其实挺具有讽刺意味的，很难对这个概念下一个清晰的定义。我发现的最好描述之一，其实是在 2010 年由俄亥俄州的研究人员撰写的一篇论文中，他们实际上讨论了感恩既是一种特质。例如，有些人天生就觉得更感恩。而且它也是一种态度或情绪。它也是我们可以为自己唤起并强行让其发生的事情。关于这一点还有更多的定义。感恩也只是一种应对反应吗？它是一种应对机制吗？感恩就像是一种精神体验吗？它只是我们必须偶然发现的东西吗？它只是自发出现的东西吗？其实很多人有
different thoughts about it. How I like to see it and how this paper defined it and gratitude in the broader sense is an appreciation of what is invaluable and meaningful to one's self, whether it is a trait, whether it is forced. It's just an appreciation. To add to this, psychologist Robert Edmonds and Michael McLeow, they are like the leading researchers on gratitude. And I like their definition as well. They define it as a two-step process, which is recognizing that something good has happened and acknowledging that someone else or something else beyond you had to play a role in it. So the first definition is really like it's just feeling like the world or something is beautiful and being able to notice it. The second definition that we're
不同的看法。我如何看待它，以及这篇论文是如何定义它的，在更广泛的意义上，感恩是对对自己而言无价且有意义的事物的欣赏，无论它是一种特质，还是被勉强做到的。它只是一种欣赏。除此之外，心理学家罗伯特·埃蒙斯（Robert Emmons）和迈克尔·麦卡洛（Michael McCullough），他们是感恩研究领域的领军人物。我也喜欢他们的定义。他们将感恩定义为一个两步的过程，即认识到发生了好事，并承认你之外的其他人或事物在其中发挥了作用。所以第一个定义实际上就像是——它只是觉得世界或某事物很美好，并且能够注意到它。我们正在研究的第二个
working with is that you're able to attribute it to something. In other words, it's not just an experience. It's also a feeling of being connected, but also supported more broadly, whether it's by your family, whether it's by the God you believe in, by the universe, by nature, whatever. whatever it is, there's an appreciation for that outside force. Psychologically, gratitude is seen as just like mental superpower. Why is that? Well, firstly, because it promotes positive appraisal or positive reappraisal. Essentially, why that's so powerful is because bad things are always going to happen.
定义是，你能够将它归因于某种东西。换句话说，它不仅是一种体验。它也是一种感觉，既有一种联系感，也有更广泛的支持感，无论是来自你的家庭，来自你信仰的神，来自宇宙，来自自然，还是无论什么。无论它是什么，对那种外在力量都有一种感激之情。在心理学上，感恩被视为一种心理超级英雄能力。这是为什么呢？首先，因为它促进了积极评估或积极重新评估。本质上，为什么这如此强大，因为坏事总会发生。
Terrible things, annoying things, frustrating things are always going to occur. You can't change that. You can change how your brain interpret. these experiences. Instead of fixating on what went wrong, gratitude allows you to retrain your mind to notice what's still working. You might not know this, but our brains are actually wired by default to have a negativity bias, basically to see the worst in things, to see the worst in people, to see the worst in circumstances. This has actually been a good thing in the past. It meant that we are more attuned to threats, to danger, to the poisonous plants, the big saber-toothed tigers.
可怕的事情、烦人的事情、令人沮丧的事情总是会发生。你无法改变这一点。你可以改变你的大脑如何解释这些经历。感恩没有专注于出错的地方，而是允许你重新训练你的大脑，去注意到那些仍然在运作的事情。你可能不知道，默认情况下，我们的大脑其实带有消极偏差，基本上就是看到事情最糟糕的一面，看到人最坏的一面，看到环境最糟糕的一面。在过去，这其实是一件好事。这意味着我们对威胁、危险、有毒植物、巨大的剑齿虎更加敏感。
But it also means that left unchecked, our minds are naturally quite pessimistic. Gratitude, though, is the counterbalance to this that allows us to kind of really just zoom out and see the full picture, not just the negative or shadowy parts. If we take a look at how this works cognitively, there's a few processes that are involved here. I feel like people talk about gratitude all the time. No one talks about what it's actually doing to your brain inside the skull of ours. First, gratitude allows us to direct our attention more conveniently or positively to things that we actually want to see. You can't appreciate good things if you don't look for them, right?
但这也意味着，如果不加控制，我们的思想自然会相当悲观。然而，感恩是对此的平衡机制，它让我们能够真正地放大视野，看到全景，而不仅仅是消极或阴暗的部分。如果我们看一下这是如何在认知上运作的，其中涉及几个过程。我觉得人们一直在谈论感恩。没有人谈论它对我们头骨内部的大脑究竟做了什么。首先，感恩使我们能够更方便或更积极地将注意力转向我们实际想看到的事物。如果你不寻找美好的事物，你就无法欣赏它们，对吧？
And if you don't direct yourself to notice them, gratitude builds that skill. The next is memory encoding. When we focus on positive experiences and we repeat them through those common exercises of a gratitude journal or reflection or speaking openly about them, those memories get encoded more deeply. The same way that when you study by writing and rehearsing and reflecting on your knowledge, this is objectively better than just like reading your notes or listening to the lecture. Research that was published in the Journal of Positive Psychology found that so-called grateful memories actually showed less fading over time, even compared to other positive memories.
如果你不引导自己去注意到它们，感恩就能培养这种技能。接下来是记忆编码。当我们专注于积极的体验，并通过感恩日记、反思或公开谈论这些常见练习来重复它们时，这些记忆就会被更深地编码。就像你通过写作、排练和反思你的知识来进行学习一样，这客观上比仅仅阅读你的笔记或听讲座要好。发表在《积极心理学杂志》（Journal of Positive Psychology）上的一项研究发现，所谓的感恩记忆在随着时间推移时表现出更少的褪色，甚至与其他积极记忆相比也是如此。
This has actually seen a lot in dementia patients who can remember really beautiful memories with their family when they were kids, when they were younger. they're encoded almost in a separate way to other kinds of memories, mainly because they are appraised as valuable. Because they are so significant and they carry meaning, our brain kind of locks them in like this sneaky safe that it has at the back, meaning that when everything else starts to fade and decay, they remain. There's also an aspect of emotional regulation going on here. Gratitude activates the prefrontal cortex. This is the part of the brain that is responsible for emotional regulation. If you're going through a really tough time and you're stressed
这在痴呆症患者身上实际上很常见，他们可以记住小时候、年轻时与家人在一起的非常美好的回忆。它们的编码方式几乎与其他类型的记忆不同，主要是因为它们被评估为有价值的。因为它们意义重大且承载着意义，所以我们的大脑会像把它锁在后方的一个狡猾保险箱里一样把它锁起来，这意味着当其他一切开始褪色和腐烂时，它们依然存在。这里也存在一个情绪调节的方面。感恩激活了前额叶皮层。这是大脑中负责情绪调节的部分。如果你经历了一段非常艰难的时期，感到压力山大
and you're frustrated, what gratitude actually does is allow this part of your brain to, I guess, work better by having a more rational perspective and truthful perspective on your circumstances. It allows you to hold two truths at the same time. This moment is hard, but it's not always going to be hard. There is more than this. That is an incredible ability to have. Also, we have to talk about this from a more social, less individualized standpoint. Gratitude has been proven to increase pro-social behavior and when practiced on an individual level to actually make a community and a society better.
并且感到沮丧，感恩实际所做的是让大脑的这一部分，我想说，通过对你的环境有更理性和真实的视角来更好地运作。它允许你同时持有两个真理。这一刻很难，但它不会一直很难。除了这个还有更多。拥有这种能力是不可思议的。此外，我们必须从更具社会化、去个性化的角度来讨论这个问题。事实证明，感恩可以增加亲社会行为，当在个人层面进行实践时，实际上可以使社区和社会变得更好。
kindness, empathy, generosity, they all increase when people have a higher level of personal gratitude. We are more likely to act in favorable ways to others and to be acting positively and strengthening relationships when we feel like there is good in the world and that other people possess good as well. So gratitude is like incredible for society as well. It's like something that really does like mend and heal fractured systems. So what does this actually do to the brain like neurologically? That was like cognitively what's happening like to our neurons, to our synapses, to yeah, to this big organ. Well, I can tell you using this 2015 FMRI study from these people at Indiana University. So in this study, they basically asked participants to write down letters of
当人们拥有更高水平的个人感恩时，善良、同理心、慷慨都会增加。当我们觉得世界上有美好，并且其他人也拥有美好时，我们更有可能以对他人有利的方式行事，积极行动并巩固关系。所以感恩对社会来说也是不可思议的。它就像是可以真正修复和治愈破裂系统的事物。那么这在神经学上对大脑到底做了什么？那是认知上正在发生的事情，对我们的神经元，对我们的突触，对，对这个巨大的器官。嗯，我可以告诉你，通过印第安纳大学（Indiana University）这些人的 2015 年 fMRI 研究。在这项研究中，他们基本上要求参与者写信给
gratitude to people in their lives. They didn't have to send the letters. They just had to write the letters that was enough to a grandmother, to an aunt, to an uncle or a brother, whoever it was. Three months later, when those same participants were scanned in the fMRI machines, their brains showed increased activity in the medial prefrontal cortex. That's the region involved in emotional regulation, in learning and decision making. Like there was physical change. to how their brain was operating. The researchers concluded that gratitude has a long-lasting neural footprint, and they saw that footprint, I guess, entrenched deeper when people did this over and over and over again.
生活中的人表达感恩。他们不必把信寄出去。他们只需要写下那些给祖母、姑姑、叔叔或兄弟姐妹或其他任何人的信就足够了。三个月后，当同一批参与者在 fMRI 机器中接受扫描时，他们的大脑显示内侧前额叶皮层的活动增加。那是参与情绪调节、学习和决策的区域。这甚至对大脑的运作方式产生了物理改变。研究人员得出的结论是，感恩具有持久的神经足迹，而且当人们一遍又一遍地这样做时，他们看到这种足迹，我想，扎根得更深。
Essentially, this practice changed the brain's baseline response to both positive and negative experiences. There was also a further 2015 study published in Frontiers in Psychology, also using fMRI scanners, which basically induced gratitude in participants and then scanned their brain at the time. Instead of just giving these people like random gratitude prompts, instead of asking them just to write letters of gratitude, they told them stories that were really precious and beautiful. These stories actually came from real Holocaust survivors who'd been helped by strangers during the war, people who had risked their own lives to offer food, to offer shelter, to offer protection. And the participants were asked to imagine themselves as this person being helped and being rescued,
本质上，这种练习改变了大脑对积极和消极体验的基线反应。2015 年发表在《心理学前沿》（Frontiers in Psychology）上的另一项研究也使用了 fMRI 扫描仪，该研究基本上在参与者身上诱发了感恩之情，然后当时扫描了他们的大脑。他们没有给这些人随机的感恩提示，也没有仅仅要求他们写感恩信，而是给他们讲述了非常珍贵和美丽的真实故事。这些故事实际上来自真正的犹太人大屠杀幸存者，他们在战争期间曾得到陌生人的帮助，那些冒着生命危险提供食物、提供住所、提供保护的人。研究人员要求参与者想象自己就是那个被帮助和获救的人，
to picture that moment, to feel what it would have been like to receive that kind of help when you were just like so desperate. And as they did that, the scans showed significant activation in a couple of areas. the ventral striatum and the nucleus accumbents, both key parts of the brain's reward system. Long names, all you need to know is that these are the areas that are most active when we experience pleasure, love or deep connection. And that activity increased even after the story was over. What's so beautiful about this study is that it shows that gratitude isn't just like something that's nice. It's not just surface level. It's like viscerally rewarding. Like the reward is something that we can
想象那个时刻，去感受当你在那种绝望中得到那种帮助时的感受。当他们这样做时，扫描显示出几个区域显著激活。腹侧纹理（ventral striatum）和伏隔核（nucleus accumbents），这两个都是大脑奖励系统的关键部分。名字很长，你只需要知道，当我们体验到快乐、爱或深层连接时，这些区域是最活跃的。即使在故事结束后，这种活动仍然在增加。这项研究的美妙之处在于它表明感恩不仅仅是件美好的事。它不仅停留在表面。它是发自肺腑的奖励。就像这种奖励是我们
literally see. And what's even more interesting was that they didn't even have to perform gratitude themselves to have this feeling. No one in this study actually received anything. Like it was entirely empathetic. Just imagining the kind of generosity was like enough to trigger the brain's reward circuits. When people say gratitude changes your brain, this is what they're talking about. This is what they are referring to. There is hard science behind why it's recommended. But, and this is equally an important thing to remember, only under the right conditions. Gratitude isn't something that we can actually always access. And it might not actually always be helpful. Sometimes it can backfire. Sometimes it can leave us feeling worse than before. And that's
可以字面意义上看到的。更有趣的是，他们甚至不需要自己去实践感恩就能有这种感觉。这项研究中的没有人真正收到任何东西。这完全是同理心的。仅仅想象那种慷慨就足以触发大脑的奖励回路。当人们说感恩会改变你的大脑时，他们谈论的就是这个。这就是他们所指的。为什么推荐它背后是有硬科学支持的。但是，同样重要的是要记住，只有在正确的条件下。感恩并不是我们总是能够获得的东西。而且它实际上可能并不总是那么有用。有时它可能会适得其反。有时它甚至会让我们感觉比以前更糟糕。那是
like a part of the conversation that I don't think people really want to have all the time. But we are going to have it today. How could gratitude possibly be bad for us? We're going to answer that question after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
对话中我认为人们并不真的总是想谈论的一部分。但我们今天就要谈谈它。感恩怎么可能对我们有害呢？短暂休息后，我们将回答这个问题。2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out. on the Look Back at it podcast.
我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是 TWA%。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？还是坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以去了解一下。在《回首当年》播客中。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
我是 Sam Jett。我是 Alex English。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈 80 年代的快克（crack，一种毒品）。
To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
明确地说，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克的日子，但为了让你知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出有一条贯穿始终的线索。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
现在我们还把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你把那句话说完。对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首当年》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难之路》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的心理治疗师 Kear Games。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different
而且我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的
intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。和我 Kear Games 一起，在我的新播客中进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话，
learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency.
《艰难之路》。打开你的免费 iHeartRadio App。搜索“learn the hard way”并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己成为了一起亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出明显的矛盾之处。
in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
在她的故事里。这开启了一场历时多年的法庭之争，以证明真相。埃伦斯女士，这份特定的检测报告是你篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改了一次检测报告。这需要一大批网络侦探出动来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯平（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends,
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《闺蜜》的新一季中，
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target.
天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会的竟然都是同一个多产的骗子。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓我将成为他最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So here's where it gets a little bit tricky. Gratitude when it's real and when it's self-motivated is really fantastic. When it bubbles up naturally, it's even more fantastic. You know, we all have those moments where we're just like, wow, I'm so lucky to be here.
他会得到应有的下场。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜》。所以，事情变得有点棘手了。当感恩是真实的、自发的时，它是非常棒的。当它自然地涌现时，就更棒了。你知道，我们都有过这样的时刻，当时我们会想，哇，我太幸运能来到这里了。
This is such a beautiful day. You go searching for that feeling. You feel incredible. You feel like there's a lightness to you. The moment that gratitude becomes something we're told to feel or something that we owe because of our circumstances, it shifts from being an emotion to being a performance. And it stops being a resource that helps us and starts. essentially becoming a tool for emotional suppression.
今天真是个好日子。你去寻找那种感觉。你感觉不可思议。你觉得有一种轻松感。但当感恩变成别人告诉我们要去感受的事情，或者因为我们的处境而成了我们欠下的东西时，它就从一种情绪转变为了一种表演。它不再是帮助我们的资源，而是开始。本质上变成了压抑情绪的工具。
This is where we veer into what we call toxic gratitude. This is an offshoot of toxic positivity. This is when we start to use it to bypass uncomfortable emotions. And what ends up happening is that we actually don't honor them and we don't actually process why they happen in the first place and why that just has like deeply impacted us. you might have heard this yourself you definitely have it's very silent sometimes like the use of gratitude to kind of silence emotions that people don't want to look at is sometimes invisible
这就是我们走向所谓“有毒的感恩”的地方。这是有毒的积极性（toxic positivity）的一个分支。这就是我们开始用它来绕过不舒服的情绪的时候。结果就是，我们实际上并没有尊重它们，也没有真正处理它们最初为什么会发生，以及为什么这给我们带来了如此深刻的冲击。你可能自己也听过这种话，你肯定听过，有时它非常安静，比如用感恩来压制人们不想面对的情绪有时是无形的
but it sounds like it could have been worse it sounds like at least i have a roof over my head it sounds like you know there's someone out there who has it harder than me so i'm just going to shut up about it. And the thing is, those statements are totally true. Yeah, someone does have it worse than you. Like, people do have it harder than you. Having that kind of awareness and perspective is important. It also doesn't undercut the fact that if something is painful and sucky for you, it's still painful and sucky for you. Like, how I like to, I always say this to my friends and I always say this to myself, someone with a broken arm, it's still going to, like their arm still, like, their arm still hurts whether or not someone else has a broken spine. Like, it's entirely separate. They are still
但听起来可能会是“情况本可能会更糟”；听起来像是“至少我还有个遮风挡雨的地方”；听起来像是“你知道，外面有人比我过得更惨，所以我要闭嘴了”。问题是，那些说法完全是正确的。是的，确实有人比你过得更惨。是的，确实有人比你过得更艰难。拥有那种觉知和视角是很重要的。但这并不能掩盖这样一个事实：如果某件事对你来说是痛苦和糟糕的，那它对你来说依然是痛苦和糟糕的。就像我喜欢的那样，我总是对我的朋友这么说，我也总是对自己这么说，一个胳膊骨折的人，他们的胳膊依然会，就像他们的胳膊依然，无论别人是否脊椎骨折，他们的胳膊依然会痛。这完全是两码事。他们依然
feeling all that pain in themselves. Like, someone else's suffering doesn't like undercut it. There's not only a certain amount of suffering that can go around. We cannot have this idea that if your suffering isn't the absolute worst kind, you do not deserve to feel it. And sometimes the use of gratitude as a solution to these feelings is a way that we actually make people believe that. This is a podcast that I love called Live Happy Now, big fan, big fan of that podcast. And I was listening to an episode that they did with Whitney Goodman talking about the impact of toxic positivity. And what she said was that toxic positivity denies an emotion. It denies a feeling, which is actually like just as bad as what that feeling might be eliciting in the first place. When we use toxic
在自己身上感受着所有的痛苦。别人的痛苦并不能削减它。世界上可供承受的痛苦并不是只有一定的量。我们不能有这种想法：如果你的痛苦不是绝对最糟糕的那种，你就不配去感受它。有时，利用感恩作为这些感觉的解决方案，正是我们让人们相信这一点的一种方式。我非常喜欢的一个播客叫《Live Happy Now》，我是它的超级粉丝，我是那个播客的超级粉丝。当时我正在听他们的一期节目，其中 Whitney Goodman 谈到了有毒积极性的影响。她说的是，有毒积极性否定了一种情绪。它否定了一种感觉，这实际上和这种感觉最初可能引发的事情一样糟糕。当我们使用有毒的
positivity, we're basically telling ourselves like this emotion shouldn't exist. It's wrong. And so not only are we feeling the feeling, we're also feeling shame about the feeling. And it's obviously impossible to ignore it anyways because we know it does exist, otherwise we wouldn't be feeling it right now. And so the whole situation becomes a lot more confusing. Refusing an emotion, or not feeling it doesn't make you more healed because it actually means that the battle between you and that emotion is probably more of a vicious daily thing than if you processed it appropriately in the first place. If you actually let yourself just not be grateful for a little while, if you just let yourself be like, this just really, really sucks. And I don't want to be grateful
积极性时，我们基本上是在告诉自己，这种情绪不应该存在。这是不对的。所以我们不仅在感受这种感觉，我们还对这种感觉感到羞耻。而且无论如何它显然是不可能被忽视的，因为我们知道它确实存在，否则我们现在就不会有这种感觉了。所以整个情况变得更加令人困惑。拒绝一种情绪，或者不感受它，并不能让你变得更被治愈，因为这实际上意味着你和那情绪之间的斗争可能比你最初适当地处理它时更像是一场恶性的日常拉锯战。如果你真的让自己暂时不要心怀感恩，如果你只是让自己说，这真的很糟糕、很糟糕。我不想对我的处境心怀感恩
for my situation. I don't want to be grateful for what else I have. I don't necessarily want to be resilient right now. I don't want to be the bigger person. I just want to have some self-pity. That's actually, and you may not think that I would say this, honestly, totally fine. Gratitude just sometimes doesn't feel accessible to you. And trying to force it to be actually creates this really weird paradox where the more you try, the harder and more elusive it becomes. Gratitude requires a certain baseline level of safety. It requires the belief that even subconsciously, you know, you're okay to relax. Like, you're okay to take in once around you. When your nervous system is dysregulated when it's stuck in fight, flight, freeze, or fawn, your brain like is all
我不想对拥有的其他东西心怀感恩。我现在不一定想变得有韧性。我不想当那个顾全大局的人。我只想有一点自我怜悯。事实上，你可能不会认为我会这么说，老实说，这完全没问题。有时感恩就是让你觉得无法企及。而试图强迫自己去感恩，实际上会产生一个非常奇怪的悖论，即你越是尝试，它就变得越难、越难以捉摸。感恩需要一定基线水平的安全感。它需要一种信念，即使是在潜意识里，你知道，你可以放松。你可以放松下来，接受周围的一切。当你的神经系统失调，陷入战斗、逃跑、僵持或讨好状态时，你的大脑会把全部精力
focused on living through and getting through this experience. So it's not going to be scanning your surroundings for beauty or blessings. It's scanning for threats and threats only. It is not a choice in that moment to be ungrateful. It is actually just plain inaccessible. When we don't feel safe, the part of us that connects us, that feels joy, that expresses appreciation, it just goes offline. Because from an evolutionary perspective, again, it's not immediately necessary for our survival. The body can't access gratitude if it doesn't believe the world is safe enough to let its guard down. And yet, that's often when again, people double down. I saw another article from the psychologist Susan David where she talks about this cultural obsession with like good
都放在经历并挺过这段经历上。所以它不会去扫描周围的美丽或祝福。它只会扫描威胁，而且只扫描威胁。那一刻不感恩并不是一种选择。实际上它只是根本无法企及。当我们感到缺乏安全感时，我们体内那些与他人连接、感到快乐、表达欣赏的部分就会直接下线。因为从进化的角度来看，同样，这对于我们的生存并不是立竿见影的必要条件。如果身体不相信这个世界安全到足以放下防备，它就无法获得感恩。然而，这往往又是人们加倍努力的时候。我看到心理学家 Susan David 的另一篇文章，她谈到了这种对所谓“好氛围”的文化迷恋，以及这实际上是如何导致更多情绪脆弱性的。当我们不被允许说出痛苦时，我们就无法处理它。未处理的痛苦并不会神奇地消失，
vibes and how that actually creates more emotional fragility. When we're not allowed to name pain, we can't process it. An unprocessed pain doesn't magically vanish. the same way that energy doesn't magically vanish. It just hides behind all the gratitude bandages until like that defense mechanism doesn't work anymore. And look, I'm not saying that gratitude is bad. It's just that like it can't be forced from a place of fear or from a place of shame. It can't be forced from a place of I should, of shoulds. Maybe that's the best way to say it. sometimes like the kindest thing you can do to yourself is and do for yourself is just be like yeah it's just really sucks so i want to talk about some alternatives i feel like i've been blabbing on
就像能量不会神奇地消失一样。它只是藏在所有的感恩创伤贴布后面，直到那种防御机制不再起作用。听着，我并不是说感恩不好。只是它不能从恐惧或羞耻的角度被强迫出来。它不能从“我应该”的角度被强迫出来。也许最好的说法是，有时你对自己能做的最善良的事，以及为自己做的事，就是说，是的，这真的很糟糕，所以我想谈谈一些替代方案。我觉得我刚才一直在喋喋不休地谈论这个，当感恩遥不可及的时候，还有什么别的选择呢？因为我们确实需要某种可以依附的东西，
about that for a while when gratitude is inaccessible what's what else is there because we do actually need some kind of thing to to hold on to um what might that be if gratitude feels too heavy one of these recommendations that i heard from someone was to just look for niceness instead. Looking for something nice feels a lot more neutral, feels way less intimidating than being like, you have to find something that you are grateful for 100% absolutely. Just look for one small thing each day that's like you just think is cool or you just think is beautiful.
那可能会是什么呢？如果感恩感觉太沉重，我听到有人给出的建议之一就是去寻找美好。寻找一些美好的事物感觉要中立得多，比起被告知“你必须 100% 绝对找到让你感恩的事物”，这种做法的压迫感要小得多。每天只寻找一件你觉得很酷或很美的小事。
You're not necessarily grateful for it. But, you know, it was really nice that the pavement smelled really beautiful after it rained day. It was really nice that like you saw that child holding that flower on the bus. I'm not necessarily grateful for it, but it was enjoyable. It was nice to see that. When we lessened the pressure to feel this like huge expansive feeling and this expansive like impact of some outside force on our lives, we can start to just welcome in a few more moments of just like joy and pleasure and contentment throughout our day. The next thing to do if you're finding it hard to be grateful for what you have and for your life is just to do something completely new. Sometimes, and especially when
你不一定对它感恩。但是，你知道，下雨天之后人行道闻起来真的很香，这真的很美好。你在公交车上看到那个孩子拿着一朵花，真的很美好。我未必对它感恩，但它令人愉快。看到那一幕很美好。当我们减轻去感受这种巨大、广阔的感觉以及某种外在力量对我们生活的巨大影响的压力时，我们就可以开始在日常生活中多迎来一些快乐、喜悦和满足的时刻。如果你发现很难对你拥有的东西和你的生活心怀感恩，接下来要做的就是做一些完全新鲜的事情。有时，特别是当
life feels hard, we find it difficult to access gratitude because everything feels the same. Then, like, you add a layer of like, this just, I'm just feeling crap onto that. Like, it just gets even worse. So pursue novelty over gratitude. Go to a new part of your city for the day. Make like a buckle list for where you live. Just wander around. Study at the public library instead of studying at home. Maybe change up your weekly routine if you can. Like start cooking new meals in the evening. Choose like an elaborate dessert recipe and commit to making it. Do something on Friday night that's not drinking. Go and like explore or go to your local bouldering gym. Go to like, I don't know, a painting class. Just like do something else. You know what me and my friends did the other day?
生活感觉艰难时，我们觉得很难获得感恩，因为一切感觉都是一样的。然后，就像，你在上面加了一层“我感觉糟透了”的感觉——情况只会变得更糟。所以，去追求新鲜感而不是感恩。去你所在城市的从未去过的新地方待上一天。为你居住的地方做一个愿望清单。四处闲逛。去公共图书馆学习，而不是在家学习。如果可以的话，也许改变一下你的每周常规。比如晚上开始做新的饭菜。选择一个精致的甜点食谱，并承诺把它做出来。周五晚上做点不是喝酒的事。去探索，或者去你当地的抱石馆。去，我不知道，上个绘画课。只要做点别的就行了。你知道我和我朋友前几天做了什么吗？
we were having this conversation of like, I'm so sick of like going out drinking on like a Saturday or Friday night and like everything in the city feels the same. So we went to a trampoline park like the one you used to go to when you were 12 years old and like someone would always end up like breaking something or like ripping their jeans.
我们当时在聊这个话题，我说，我厌倦了周六或周五晚上出去喝酒，感觉城市里的每件事都一样。所以我们去了一个蹦床公园，就像你 12 岁时常去的那种，而且总有人最后会摔断什么东西或者把牛仔裤撕破。
And it was the best night ever. Having novel experiences has been evidenced time and time again to be essential for adaptability and for your overall well-being. Like people actually cannot thrive in situations that are completely and constantly the same. They need new stimulus. So if you're not feeling grateful, that might be a solution. Another way to experience like newness is to put yourself in someone else's shoes
那是史上最棒的一个夜晚。事实证明，拥有新奇的体验对于适应能力和整体健康至关重要。人们确实无法在完全且持续相同的环境中蓬勃发展。他们需要新的刺激。所以如果你没有感受到感恩，那可能就是解决方案。体验新鲜感的另一种方式是设身处地为他人着想
and to, you know, create gratitude for somebody else if you can't experience it for yourself. Volunteering, acts of kindness, those kinds of things are deeply. powerful. Try and do like one kind thing a day for the next two weeks. Not only does this like give you a sense of purpose, like I'm changing somebody else's life, even if they don't notice it. It also allows others to be grateful for you. And that can create feedback for modeling gratitude in general. When you're finding it really hard to access it, maybe you just need to create more of it for other people and it will come back to you in time. Similar to like both of these like, is just being curious.
如果你无法为自己体验感恩，那就试着为他人创造感恩。做志愿者、行善这类事情具有深远的力量。试着在接下来的两周里，每天做一件善事。这不仅能给你带来使命感，觉得“我在改变别人的生活”，哪怕他们并没有察觉；它还能让别人对你心怀感激，从而为总体上的感恩建模提供反馈。当你发现自己很难感受到感恩时，也许你只是需要为其他人多创造一些，它最终会回馈给你。与前两点类似，另一点就是保持好奇心。
Novelty, curiosity, somewhat similar, but it just keeps the mind open when you can't necessarily access these absolute positive emotions. Just try and explore, just try and be interested in life, try and find new things that you can learn about and then see if gratitude comes.
新鲜感和好奇心有些相似，但它能在你无法必然获得这些绝对积极的情绪时，让你的思想保持开放。试着去探索，试着对生活保持兴趣，试着寻找你可以学习的新事物，然后看看感恩是否会随之而来。
Some questions you might also want to ask yourself to prompt this in your own life is like when I'm looking at an experience, I might see it as only good or only bad. What is the gray area? What actually might this experience be teaching me that I don't have to be grateful for, but I don't have to be terrified of either? What might this be preparing me for? Or, you know, if this was like a chapter of my life in a movie or a book,
为了在你的生活中激发这一点，你可能还会问自己一些问题，比如当我审视一段经历时，我可能会认为它非好即坏。那么灰色地带是什么？这段经历实际上可能在教导我什么？我虽然不必对此感恩，但也无需为此感到恐惧。这可能是在为我的什么做准备？或者，你知道的，如果这是我人生电影或书中一个章节，
and I was someone watching from the outside looking in, what's the purpose of this moment? Can I see where this is guiding me to in the future? What should my character do next? Instead of seeing things in like absolute, this is only good, this is only bad. Yeah, like there's zones us in on like, what's in the middle? What's like the meat of this situation? What am I meant to be learning? And this like isn't supposed to be invalidating or it's not supposed to romanticize your pain. It just encourages is just to stay engaged with like the nuances of life and accept that like just because something doesn't make sense yet doesn't mean that it won't down the line like it's an acknowledgement that
而我是个旁观者，那么这个时刻的目的是什么？我能看出它在将我引导向未来的什么方向吗？我的角色接下来应该怎么做？而不是用绝对的眼光来看待事物——这只有好，这只有坏。是的，这会让我们聚焦于：中间是什么？这个情况的核心是什么？我注定要学到什么？这并不是要否定你的痛苦，也不是要将你的痛苦浪漫化。它只是鼓励我们保持参与，去体会生活的细微差别，并接受这样一件事：仅仅因为某件事现在还说不通，并不意味着它以后也说不通。这是一个承认，
especially if you're in your 20s like you're still learning you're still growing and adapting through life this might be the worst thing that's ever happened to you now but life will get bigger and like be able to hold more space for new and better things I think the biggest takeaway from today is that gratitude is like fabulous. It's like I honestly think it's like a human gift. It's a miracle in many ways that we can like appreciate things so deeply that the only thing we can do is say that some otherworldly thing must be responsible for it. It's so beautiful that we can see beauty and just like it's honestly an indescribable emotion.
特别是如果你正处于二十多岁，你仍在学习，仍在成长，并在生活中不断适应。这可能是你经历过的最糟糕的事情，但生活会变得更广阔，能够为新的、更好的事物容纳更多空间。我认为今天最大的收获是，感恩就像是一件神奇的礼物。在很多方面，它是一个奇迹，我们可以如此深刻地欣赏事物，以至于我们唯一能做的就是说，某种超自然的力量一定是它的幕后推手。我们能看到美，这真是太美妙了，而且这坦率说是一种难以言喻的情绪。
Like I imagine trying to just describe like gratitude to an alien. I just like feel like they probably wouldn't understand it. That doesn't mean that it's a moral test. You don't have to be relentlessly positive. You don't have to be grateful all the time just because it's a beautiful feeling. You don't have to pretend everything's fine. I think it's just important to know that like you're allowed to have a diversity of emotions. But if you can access gratitude, it's not going to be a quick fix.
就像我想象着向一个外星人描述感恩。我只是觉得他们可能无法理解。但这并不意味着这是一场道德考验。你不需要无休止地保持积极。你不需要仅仅因为这是一种美好的感觉就一直心存感激。你没必要假装一切都好。我认为重要的是要知道，你被允许拥有多样化的情绪。但如果你能感受到感恩，它不会是一个快速见效的解决方法。
It's not going to be some vitamin, but it is something that you can like, come back to that might make life just feel a little bit better, that might be able to like hold your hand through grief and through exhaustion and through hard times and just give you like, it's like a nice place to like go and lay your head down when like everything else in the world feels really terrible. Doesn't mean you like a morally obligated to feel it all the time. It's just like a superpower and it's this brilliant thing that we're very lucky to have when we really need it. So, Thank you so much for listening to this episode. If you have made it this far, what's something you're grateful for? Please leave a comment below. Share why that makes you feel grateful.
它不会是什么维生素，但它是一个你可以回溯的事物，它可能会让生活感觉稍微好一点，能够在悲伤、精疲力竭和艰难时期携手陪伴你，给你提供一个舒适的避风港——当你觉得世界上的一切都糟透了的时候，可以去那里靠一靠。这并不意味着你在道德上有义务时时刻刻都感受到它。它只是一种超能力，也是我们在真正需要它时非常幸运能拥有的绝妙事物。非常感谢你收听本期节目。如果你听到了这里，你有什么感到感激的事吗？请在下方留言，分享为什么那会让你感到感激。
Share, yeah, whether it's a person, whether it's a pet, whether it's like a movie, a TV show, like the best chocolate cake you've ever had. I want to hear it. I want to know. Something I'm grateful for right now is air conditioner. It's like genuinely like 40 degrees. Sydney right now. If you're like, I don't know if you do Fahrenheit, it's like over 100 degrees. And yeah, I'm so grateful for air conditioner. I'm so grateful for the people who discovered how to make air cold. So that's my little, that's my little touchstone for the day. I'm going to go to pet thinking, God, that's nice. But yeah, I appreciate you listening. Thank you again to our research assistant Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. She's amazing. We love her and
分享吧，是的，无论是某个人、某只宠物、某部电影、某部电视剧，还是你吃过的最好吃的巧克力蛋糕。我想听听。我想知道。我此刻感到感激的一件事是空调。悉尼现在气温真的高达40度。如果你习惯用华氏度的话，大概超过了100度。所以，是的，我太感谢空调了。我太感谢那些发明如何把空气变冷的人了。这就是我今天的一点小确幸。我要去撸猫，心想，真好。不过，谢谢你们的收听。再次感谢我们的研究助理莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的贡献。她太棒了。我们爱她，并且
we appreciate all of her work. If you want more from the psychology of your 20s. You can follow us on Substack if you want the transcript of this episode. You can also follow us on YouTube if you want to watch this episode or watch any of the other episodes that we have recorded for you guys in the recent months. Make sure as well that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to see what's coming up, I think we have a few meetups planned soon. So if you live in Europe, I'll be coming your way very, very soon. So stay tuned for that. But until next time, Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself.
我们感谢她的所有工作。如果你想了解更多关于《二十岁心理学》的内容，如果你想要本期节目的文字记录，可以在 Substack 上关注我们。如果你想观看本期节目，或者观看我们在过去几个月里为你录制的其他任何节目，也可以在 YouTube 上关注我们。同时也请确保在 Instagram 上关注我们，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。如果你想了解接下来有什么活动，我想我们很快会安排一些粉丝见面会。所以如果你住在欧洲，我很快就会去到你们那里。敬请期待。但在下一次见面之前，请注意安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。
Be grateful when you need to be or when you want to be. And we will talk very, very soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
在你需要时或想要时心存感激。我们很快就会再聊。欢迎收听 Look Back at It 播客。从 1979 年开始，这对我有重大意义。84 年对我来说也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black. people listen to look back at it on the iHeart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts hey what's good y'all you're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host
并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同仁喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。嘿，大家好，欢迎收听 Learn the Hard Way，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人
kear games this space is about black men's experiences having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing how many men carry a suit or armor it signals to the world that you not to be played with and just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
基尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习 Learn the Hard Way。2023 年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. The lesbian. Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。这位女同性恋。迈克尔·兰奇尼（Michael Ranchini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
这是《陷入爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the signs of mental tough. fitness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
我剖析了心理坚韧、体能的迹象，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。经历一些苦难，你将作为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人从另一端走出来。收听 2%。也就是 TWA%（注：原文口误或谐音），在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想逃脱惩罚。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们。相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust Me, Babe）。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。